مثل كل يوم يصل اوس الى مكان عمله في حي
الفاتح
اقرانه من السوريين المقيم
ين في برامج الحملات الانتخابيه خاصه تلك
التي تقودها تحالفات المعارضه التي تتوعد
بترحيلهم حاله فوزها
وهم الذين استقر بهم الحال هنا منذ عشر
سنوات
طبعا انتخابات السابقه شاهد على الموضوع
وعود انتخابيه سابقه
تكون انت ضمن البرنامج عباره عن بس شعارات
عرفت شلون يستهلكونك ويستثمرونك ويلعبون
باعصابك واعصاب اهلك وعائلتك واولادك لكن
احنا ما يعني نرجو من الموضوع كله انه
احنا نكون بعيدين عن كل هذا الموضوع لانه
احنا يعني
بعيد كل البعد عن موضوع السياسي بتركيا
تحتضن تركيا اعدادا كبيره من اللاجئين من
جنسيات مختلفه يمثل السوريون السواد
الاعظم منهم اذ استقبلت البلاد موجات كبرى
من السوريين خلال الاعوام السابقه شهدت
السنوات الاخيره ارتفاعا في حالات
الاعتداء على اللاجئين وتبنت بعض احزاب
المعارضه خطابا يوصف بالتحريض ضدهم
المعارضه التركيه باختلاف توجهاتها
استخدمت هذا الملف ضد الحكومه وبرامجها
واضحه في اعلان عزمها اخلاء البلاد بشكل
كامل من هؤلاء مبرره ذلك باسباب عده
اعاده اللاجئين امر حكمي لا مفر منه الحزب
الحاكم فتح الباب على مصرعيه للاجئين دون
قيد او شرط ودون تخطيط فنتج عن ذلك ارتفاع
في الاسعار وبات صعبا على المواطن التركي
توفير احتياجاته
الحزب الحاكم بدوره يتهم المعارضه بتسييس
هذا الملف ويؤكد ان مساله اللاجئين التزام
اخلاقي بالنسبه للحكومه
المعارضه لجات الى الكذب وروجت لشائعات في
موضوع اللاجئين من قبيل اعفائهم من
الضرائب ومنحهم الرواتب وهذا كله غير صحيح
التزامنا في هذا الملف نابع من التزامنا
بتاريخنا وثقافتنا وديننا المشترك مع
هؤلاء اللاجئين
يتابع اللاجئون البرامج الانتخابيه بدرجه
لا تقل عن متابعه الاتراك لها
ويطرحون تساؤلات حول مصيرهم اذا اقدمت
المعارضه على تنفيذ وعودها بترحيلهم في
حال فوزها
وعن سياسه الحكومه الحاليه بشان العوده
الطوعيه ان هي فازت في الانتخابات بين
وعودهم بتسويه اوضاعهم واخرى بترحيلهم
يتارجح مصير اللاجئين في تركيا اذ وجدوا
انفسهم في لجه تجاذبات سياسيه وتحولوا الى
ماده للنقاش في حملات انتخابيه قد تحدد
مصيرهم عمر الحاجه الجزيره اسطنبول